[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-In the beginning,
"Hand to God" announced
it was coming to Broadway.
We didn't have any movie stars.
We weren't adapted from a film
or any of those guaranteed
money makers. (SHOUTING)
It was suicide.
(CALMLY) But "Hand of God"
opened, and we got amazing
reviews.
I mean look at of these
things, and that one, god.
And audiences are losing
their freakin' minds over it.
How do you like
me now, Broadway?
"Hand to God" on Broadway, for
tickets visit telecharge.com.
[END PLAYBACK]
ALAN SEALES: So please
welcome the cast, playwright,
and producer of "Hand to God."
[APPLAUSE]
Now, if you guys don't mind, for
those of you who don't know you
are, please go down the
line and introduce yourself.
BOB SAGET: My name is Bob.
I'm single.
I'm not in a program, and I'm
fortunate to be in the part
that Marc Kudisch originated
in this amazing play
with these amazing,
brilliant people
that I can't believe
I'm having such
a wonderful experience with.
And I hope to see you
all at summer camp.
I could have gone out stronger.
I'll tell the aristocrats joke.
Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: We'll
come back that.
BOB SAGET: I'll see you later.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
ROB ASKINS: He was asked to
say his name and who he plays.
BOB SAGET: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
ROB ASKINS: Oh, there you go.
There you go.
My name's Rob Askins.
I wrote the play.
BOB SAGET: Say more, come on.
ROB ASKINS: I'm
going to say more.
I'm not as interesting.
STEVEN BOYER: There's
plenty of time.
ROB ASKINS: Oh, come on,
please, let's me on to this guy.
He's so well dressed.
LUCAS MCMAHON: My name is Lucas
McMahon, the associate producer
of the show.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
I'm Michael Oberholtzer.
I play a character named Timmy.
SARAH STILES: Sarah
Stiles-- I play Jessica.
STEVEN BOYER: Steven Boyer.
I play Jason and Tyrone.
GENEVA CARR: I'm
Geneva Carr, and I
play Jason's mother, Marjorie.
BOB SAGET: Do we
go back to me now?
ALAN SEALES: If you want
to continue the joke, yeah.
ROB ASKINS: Do you want to give
my portion of the interview?
BOB SAGET: No.
ROB ASKINS: Will you
ask him my questions?
ALAN SEALES: All right, Rob,
where did the idea for the play
come from?
BOB SAGET: I can't talk anymore.
ROB ASKINS: I grew up in Texas.
My mother had a Christian
puppet ministry.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, that's real?
ROB ASKINS: That
is a real thing.
It was not like the Christian
puppet ministry in the play,
thank god.
And I've been dealing
for a long time
with self-destructive behaviors.
And I'm still dealing with
self-destructive behaviors.
ALAN SEALES: You say
that so ominously.
ROB ASKINS: Huh?
ALAN SEALES: You're like--
ROB ASKINS: I believe in tone.
ALAN SEALES: Oh,
should I interview you
like this the whole
time? (STRONG VOICE) I
should interview
very dangerously.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah, let's
do it Charlie Rose style.
ALAN SEALES: All right, cool.
ROB ASKINS: And so I
was looking for a way
to acknowledge
self-defeating behaviors,
and I was looking
for a way to do it
that would be cuddly
and easily marketable.
GENEVA CARR: Easily marketable?
ROB ASKINS: I'm so
glad they're behind me.
This is the best set up ever.
STEVEN BOYER: Is
your microphone on?
ROB ASKINS: I don't think
so, but I can project.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, it's on.
I hear him.
ROB ASKINS: And so I drew on my
past as a Christian puppeteer
and as somebody who
liked to break things.
And then I saw the
very talented people
behind me standing
together at a party.
And I said, they are the
people that can bring those two
opposing forces--
STEVEN BOYER: Like
those two drunk people
can really bring this to life.
ROB ASKINS: Right,
I saw them fighting
in an alley over a doughnut.
And somebody took off a sock.
And then the rest
is on Broadway.
ALAN SEALES: So your past
as an actual pupeteer--
I was going to ask where
Tyrone came from in terms
of being at a puppet versus a
real flesh-and-blood person,
like another actor on stage.
So it was your
past experience as
an actual Christian puppeteer?
ROB ASKINS: As an actual
Christian puppeteer--
also, I think a lot of brother
plays are divided self plays.
I think Sam Shepard's "True
West" is a divided self play.
I think obviously
Shakespeare's twin plays--
there are a lot of twin plays.
I think a lot of that has to do
with most of the time character
and personality or horse shit.
Like, we have so many voices
inside of us at all times.
BOB SAGET: Are you
putting down horse shit?
ROB ASKING: Yes, sir.
And so I was like, oh,
well, let's acknowledge
the war within the individual.
And so a puppet's a
great way to do it.
BOB SAGET: Wow, can
I ask a question?
Did you live this
childhood a little bit
of what Jason, Stephen's
character, goes through?
ROB ASKINS: It's
a great question.
There are some scenes
in the play that
are ripped from
the headlines that
are very accurate and painful.
BOB SAGET: And you used
humor to get through it?
ROB ASKINS: If you
could say that this
is getting through it, yeah.
BOB SAGET: I didn't
mean-- I didn't mean this.
ROB ASKINS: I'll lean
the fuck in, man.
I'm not scared.
BOB SAGET: Oh, I
know you're not.
ROB ASKINS: I'll
lean the fuck in.
I'm about to fall over
I'm leaning in so hard.
ALAN SEALES: So the show
pokes fun at, I guess,
several well-known
organizations,
like Sesame Street, and
actually, it sort of
spoofs "Avenue Q," which
is a spoof in itself.
ROB ASKINS: Never heard of it.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah?
And, of course,
religion-- I mean, is that
my personal
interpretation, or was
that intentional that
you kind of wrapped it
all together like that?
ROB ASKINS: Religion spoofs
itself a lot of the time.
ALAN SEALES: Fair enough.
ROB ASKINS: We don't
have to reach real far
to put some spin on that ball.
But at the same time-- I
love the smattering giggles.
Those are my favorite.
I can't get through
the goddamn lines.
But at the same time,
there is much good,
and there is much
worthy and much worth
focusing attention
and human interest.
So I think in the same way
that personality and character
sometimes are our
strategies, so too
is an opinion on something
as complex as the human
relationship to the divine.
And sometimes it takes
both laughter and tears
to get at it.
ALAN SEALES: I'm going to
let that sit for a second.
That's good.
Lucas, how did you get involved,
in the first place, yourself?
LUCAS MCMAHON: So
I actually deserve
no personal credit for it.
The lead producer of the
show, Kevin McCollum,
who I work with, but
couldn't be here today
because he's in Washington,
DC for the opening
of "Motown, the Musical," which
is another one of our shows
which is coming back to
Broadway this summer.
And I mention it
only because I'm
hoping for another free
meal in your cafeteria,
but, anyway, he's there.
So he actually saw the play at
the Ensemble Studio Theater,
the roots of which Rob
and Steven and Geneva
can talk a little
bit more about.
But he, I think, recognized
the real brilliance
of this playwright right
here and these actors,
and saw something really
unique and that needed
to be seen by as many people.
Commercial theater
is about bringing
the work of really great
artists to as many people
as possible and as many
places as possible.
And so Kevin, who has also
produced "Rent" and "Avenue
Q" and "In the Heights,"
so a bunch of big flops.
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
GENEVA CARR: No
vision, that guy.
LUCAS MCMAHON: Yeah, exactly.
Really fell in love
with this show.
I started working with
Kevin about six months
after that, when he had been
developing the show with Rob
and Moritz, the Director.
And then we brought the
show to MCC theater,
which is a wonderful off
Broadway theater company.
Yes, it deserves a
big round of applause.
Steven and Geneva were
in the show off-off
Broadway at Ensemble
Studio Theater,
and then Sarah and Michael
joined the show at MCC,
as well as a new design team
and a bunch of other people
who came together to bring
you the production that
is now on Broadway today.
We opened in February
of 2014 at MCC,
down at the Lucille
Lortel theater.
And we're very blessed to
receive a wonderful reception
from the audiences
and the critics.
And then moved to the show to
the main stem, to Broadway.
So that's kind of
a brief history
of how the show came together
and moved to the Booth Theater
where it is today.
ALAN SEALES: So
Steven and Geneva,
you guys have been around, you
said, from the very beginning,
right?
I'm looking behind me.
I've got to move back.
STEVEN BOYER: Hi.
ALAN SEALES: Sorry, camera guys.
There we go.
Yes, so you guys have been
around from the very beginning.
So how have you seen this
show like evolve over time?
STEVEN BOYER: Take it.
GENEVA CARR: Oy, well,
this is actually,
I would say that it's the fourth
production that Steven and I
have done together of the show.
Because the original
show that we did,
we did several readings
of "Hand to God"
because Rob wrote it in 2011.
So we did several
readings of the play,
and then we did a showcase at
Ensemble Studio Theater, which
is where you don't pay
the actors anything.
They do it for free
because they love it.
And we had hit on our hands.
So they give us a mini contract,
so we did it at EST in 2012,
and Kevin came to see it in
2011 and actually funded to 2012
production off-off Broadway.
And that's one of
the amazing things
that I don't know if you know
that producers do, and Kevin
is the king of it, is
if he finds something,
he'll work with it until
he thinks it's ready.
So then he moved us to
MCC, which is off Broadway,
and we got Sarah and Michael
and another actor Marc Kudisch
until we were lucky
enough to get Bob.
BOB SAGET: I'm changing
my name to Kudisch.
GENEVA CARR: Yeah, Bob Kudisch.
So there so many things to say
about how a play gets developed
and how it's been for
me, but in a nutshell,
the original reading with
Steven, it was a cold reading.
And they said, hey,
we're just going to do
this reading of this play.
Rob wrote this place.
He thought of you two.
ALAN SEALES:
[INAUDIBLE] the fight
in the alley about the donuts?
GENEVA CARR: Right, yeah, yeah--
yeah, we were dating-- no.
No, no, that's not true.
ALAN SEALES: Donut?
GENEVA CARR: So the
original reading,
we show up to do
this reading, and do
for those of you who
haven't seen the play,
it's really complicated.
Forget the rape scenes.
There's a puppet.
And they were going to bring--
STEVEN BOYER: That's the
quote that's going to go out.
The Google interview soundbite.
ALAN SEALES: Forget
the rape scene.
There's a puppet.
STEVEN BOYER: Cast
of "Hand of God"
says, forget the rape scene.
There's a puppet.
BOB SAGET: She did
say forget, though.
GENEVA CARR: You can
edit this, right.
ALAN SEALES: A little bit.
STEVEN BOYER: Doesn't matter
what we talk about from here
on out.
That's the pull quote.
ROB ASKINS: They're just going
to cut out the word "forget,"
so it says, rape scene--
there's a puppet.
BOB SAGET: Also it's
the strongest laugh
that's happened so far.
It could be the whole clip.
GENEVA CARR: Do you want
to take it from here?
STEVEN BOYER: I
don't know what you
were-- where were you going?
GENEVA CARR: I was going to
tell a good story about you
about this original reading.
STEVEN BOYER: Let's do it.
GENEVA CARR: We do this reading.
We show up.
And they have said
to Steven, oh, hey,
we're going to bring an oven
mitt because there's a puppet.
So Stephen, who is
the true professional
that you see before you,
decided that wasn't good enough.
So he googled easiest puppet
to make, which we sock puppet,
and he showed up to this
cold read with a sock puppet.
And from--
STEVEN BOYER: --with arms.
GENEVA CARR: Yeah, with
arms with like little hanger
arms and lipstick and
eyeshadow, I remember.
And he was two people, and
that's the trick of the show.
The show is a lot of things.
But he plays two
different people,
totally different people, that
have scenes with each other,
and it's astounding to see.
So we did reading after
reading after reading,
and it wasn't
until we met Moritz
that I knew we had the right
director because Moritz
loves a laugh, but he will
sacrifice a laugh for story.
So all this time that
we've been moving
the play, the other
thing, Rob is not
afraid to make the play better.
So I remember off Broadway,
our first 10 performances,
we had a different ending
every single night.
I had to learn new
lines every single night
until we got it right.
And then on Broadway,
the same things,
that Rob and Moritz were not
willing to sit on any laurels
that they had gotten.
They wanted to make the
show the best it could be.
And it's been massaged
in such a way that
makes it what it is today.
STEVEN BOYER: That scared
the shit out of me.
I'm always like,
everybody loves it.
Don't touch it.
I'm like, don't touch it.
We don't know the weird
alchemy that makes this work,
so please don't touch a line.
Like, I just really--
it's so frightening to me,
but Rob and Moritz were brave
enough to like slash and burn
and--
SARAH STILES: Tell you
to shut up, do it--
STEVEN BOYER: Exactly, like, and
just like bring in new pages.
And I'm like, I don't if
this is going to work.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah, but
there's something great.
Like, if we hadn't
had four productions--
do you know what I mean-- when
we were in a Broadway theater
that none of us thought
we'd ever be in?
STEVEN BOYER: Oh, yeah,
I mean, the stakes
kept getting higher and higher.
ROB ASKINS: Right, and I'm
like, I got a new ending.
And you're like,
fuck your new ending.
GENEVA CARR: And I'm
like, I want to hear it.
I want to hear it.
ROB ASKINS: Right, you're like,
you can go fuck yourselves.
I wish I had a trailer.
But that's the thing.
But then it was like, then
we all chilled the fuck out.
Do you know what I mean?
And then the work got done.
STEVEN BOYER: And
also what helps
is we put that ending up
in front of an audience,
and we're like, oh, it's better.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah.
STEVEN BOYER:
Because the reaction
from the very beginning
in 2011 and 2012
was so above and
beyond, that it's
like this can't
possibly get better.
And then it kept getting better.
And that was beyond-- I didn't
think that was possible.
GENEVA CARR: Yeah, me neither.
LUCAS MCMAHON: But
the development
of new work and new
plays, that's something
that I think a lot
of people don't
know how much goes into it.
it's not just, if you create
something and people love it,
it's how do we make
it even better.
To paraphrase Jerome
Robbins, shows
are never finished, just
abandoned for lack of time.
So I think the instinct
is always to keep working
and how do we make that
moment better and stronger.
And so the tireless work
of everyone on this stage
that we get the play
that is before you today,
which started in this
really incredible place.
But I think where it ended
is even stronger and more
affecting for the audience.
ALAN SEALES: So the only
character not on stage with us
now, obviously, is Tyrone,
or I guess, arguably he is.
But I want to roll
one video first off.
We've got two videos of Tyrone.
So I'll roll the first one
now to kind of give you
guys, if you haven't
seen the play yet,
a little bit of intro into who
Tyrone is as the puppet here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Tyrone's, he's
an amazing actor.
-Genuinely honest on a stage.
-He really likes to
think on his feet,
but he does have
some memory issues.
-No, he drinks
everything-- bottled water.
-Definitely hungover.
He's usually complaining
of a headache,
and he seems really dehydrated.
-Antifreeze.
-He really wants to kiss me.
-Nicotine oil.
-When maybe he's been
drinking a little bit,
those are kind of tough.
-The drugs.
Yeah, krokodil, have
you heard about that?
-Well, I'm sure you know,
he was a movie star,
and then his star
meter on IMD went rrr.
-Krokodil, your skin
starts to peal off.
It's from like Russia.
-I don't like to use the
term sexual harassment, but--
-He has certain talents.
One of those talents
is blackmail.
-You know, we had words.
He came at me.
-Well, not like the devil,
but like an asshole.
-I came at him.
He drew a little bit of blood.
-He has huge anger issues, but
that's what makes him so great,
you know?
-Tyrone, thanks for joining us.
-Hey, thank you for having me.
[END PLAYBACK]
ALAN SEALES: So,
Steven, you showed up.
So you read a script for the
cold reading, you were saying,
and you showed up with
your own handmade puppet.
Was that--
STEVEN BOYER: That's right.
I'm that guy.
ALAN SEALES: Was that
your first, I guess,
entry into
puppeteering, or did you
have any experience with that?
STEVEN BOYER: I'd done a show a
couple years before that called
"Jollyship The Whiz-Bang."
That's a pirate
puppet rock opera.
I only do the most
fucked up plays.
Yeah, that was by a
guy named Nick Jones.
And that was the first time
I'd done anything with puppets,
but they were very
different from this.
They weren't sock
puppets or whatever.
So I kind of learned how to
do some sort of puppeteering
during that, a few years before
the first read through of this.
ALAN SEALES: So what was your
process like for just learning
the lines?
Because like the lines
come at you so fast.
They're just whizzing by, and
it's like, you, hand, and you,
hand, you hand.
STEVEN BOYER: Well, I
mean, Jason and Tyrone
are written as--
I mean, you could
look at it is a monologue.
But it is written as
dialogue because they're
two separate characters
with completely different
personalities and brains.
And you have to-- Jason and
Tyrone will cut each other off.
They would be talking over
each other at the same time
if they could, but
all of the sound
is coming out of my mouth.
We tried a music
stand for awhile
because I had no hands
to hold the pages,
and that just--
it was very weird.
I mean, there were like
a couple music stands
in different parts of the
stage, and I'd just be like,
and I'd have to turn
the page, and be
like, I don't know where I am.
It was basically like you just
had to learn the lines at home
and come in and when
rehearsal came around,
it was just time to rehearse.
ALAN SEALES: Did you start
slow and just like gradually
speed up?
STEVEN BOYER: No, I couldn't.
It wouldn't work.
Like it was-- I just dove in.
I mean, it was--
it's-- yeah, I mean,
like even when we
were at the table,
it was hard to read it
and not do the puppet--
the naked version of the
puppet, with like the bones,
the bones of the puppet.
This is me with no clothes.
ALAN SEALES: Pixilated
puppet right here.
STEVEN BOYER: We're going
to green screen that later.
ALAN SEALES: That's right.
STEVEN BOYER: But it was--
it's hard to explain,
but when you try
and break it down,
sometimes we would try--
there's a scene between Jason
and Tyrone where Tyrone
wakes Jason up in bed.
And there's a scene in
Jason's bedroom, where Tyrone
is kind of berating him and
telling him that he wants him
to like step up and be a man.
And when I would run through
it just as Jason or just
as Tyrone, it just
didn't feel right
because they need each other,
and they're two split sides
of the same thing.
And dividing them up,
it just felt wrong.
ALAN SEALES: Which is harder for
you to play, Jason or Tyrone?
STEVEN BOYER: I
think, you know what?
I think Tyrone is actually
kind of closer to me.
I am a small--
[LAUGHTER]
I am a small, furry,
red-headed, disgusting--
with no pants or legs.
But Jason-- the thing
is that Jason is so
sort of wounded and shrinking.
He's such a-- he wants to hide
so much that putting yourself
back in that place
of what it felt
like to be a teenager that
really has no idea what you're
going to end up being like as
an adult is painful and hard.
And the further I get away
from it, the more difficult
it is to get back to that place
of-- I mean, I'm in my mid 30s
now.
I know exactly who I am,
and I feel very secure
in my personality.
But, you know, that
time in everyone's life
is very difficult.
And so getting back
to that place for
Jason is harder
for me, whereas Tyrone knows
exactly who the fuck he is.
He's the devil, which is why
I feel so much closer to him.
ALAN SEALES: Michael and Sara,
you guys came into the show,
obviously, later
into the process.
What was the audition process
like for the two of you?
SARAH STILES: Michael,
you have to tell yours.
It's so good.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
No, go ahead.
I'm practicing sleeping
with my eyes open.
GENEVA CARR: No, you do it.
You do it.
You go.
It's so good.
It's such a good story.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: No, please.
No, ladies first.
GENEVA CARR: Come
on, please, shh.
Do it.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: So hold on.
Let me wake up really quick.
OK, thank you.
Is mic on?
I don't want to be that
dickhead with the mic not on.
They're just like-- OK, it's on.
So I just-- I auditioned
for this thing.
I was one of the few
people in New York that
missed the production at
EST, and I kick myself
because I think I didn't get a
chance to see this awesome hit
play by this guy Rob Askins
and this amazing performance
by Steven Boyer and Geneva Carr.
And then I found out that they
were-- my agent sent me out
for it, and I went in for it.
And it was very rare that
I didn't get a chance
to read the entire script.
And so they gave me the
sides, and I went in,
and I just completely
played everything
like just straight--
very, very serious.
And Rob was in the room
and Moritz, the Director
and the artistic
director of MCC,
and they're just dying laughing.
And I just walked
out of there just
feeling like I was a
complete and utter failure
because my best work was
eliciting so much laughter.
And it wasn't until I went
home and actually read
the script that I
realized that that
was exactly what the play was.
And interestingly enough, it
became a challenge for me,
as the process went
on, when we did
off Broadway and on Broadway.
And there was this quote
that I came across.
It was by George Dawes Green.
Probably most of you know him.
He's from "The Moth."
I'm going to
paraphrase it, but it
was when everything
opened up for me,
and it totally
comes back to this.
He said something at the
center of every great story
is a flaw, a human flaw.
It's actually failure.
And a great storyteller
recognizes in some way
that he's a clown.
And we identify with that
because we're all clowns.
And when I read that, that
was like the point for me
where I realized it
doesn't matter what people
think of this kid Timothy.
If they laugh at
him or with him,
or if they don't laugh
at all is journey
that the permission is
there, and the story
is such that-- we've always said
it's a very serious play that's
fucking hilarious.
Do you know what I mean?
And that's what this
is that we're doing it,
and it's the best kind
of comedy, in my opinion.
And with that, I'll pass it
on to the great Sarah Stiles.
SARAH STILES: I mean,
there was an addition.
I went in.
And I was lucky.
I don't know.
I wanted a job, and
I wanted this job
because I read the script, and
I thought it was brilliant.
And I'd done a lot of
musicals, and so I really
wanted to do a play.
And so this was my first play.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
And she's amazing in it.
She really is.
You should come see Sarah.
She's so good.
She makes me crack
up all the time.
Just when I think she can't
get any dryer in her part,
she just comes on like, God,
somebody just woke me up,
and now I've got to go on stage
and-- it's so-- she's so good.
STEVEN BOYER: Comedy
scientist, Sarah.
GENEVA CARR: She is.
Her timing, it's impeccable.
ALAN SEALES: Do you guys
ever break on stage,
or is it all
perfection every night?
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
Perfection, man.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah?
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
I'm a perfec--
I'm a fucking professional.
SARAH STILES: We
have a hard time.
We have a hard time.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: But
I'm a professional always.
I never break, man.
SARAH STILES: There's one line
about a milk-stained vagina.
And if it is said incorrectly,
we can't keep it together.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
Yeah, that's true.
This is dangerous.
We have to like
separate our eye contact
because I will break with her.
SARAH STILES: Because we also,
our characters hate each other.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: Right.
SARAH STILES: So there
can't be a twinkle,
or else it's all over.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: Yeah,
and sometimes like Steve
will do something, and
I'll look at Sarah,
and she's just like, did you
just see what I just saw?
And then we just start
fucking laughing.
It's horrible.
It's very unprofessional.
SARAH STILES: And then
Steve is like, you guys.
STEVEN BOYER: Yeah,
but just with my eyes.
It's just like, juh.
SARAH STILES: Pull it together!
STEVEN BOYER: (MENACING
WHISPER) We are
in front of hundreds of people.
BOB SAGET: I'm new to this,
but when Michael has a tendency
to make me want to go up,
and I never would want to do.
So when I looked at
him onstage during
a confrontational scene--
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
Serious-- very, very serious.
BOB SAGET: Look into
this brilliant woman's
eyes because I actually
was going to crack up
like Jimmy Fallon on "SNL."
That is not a good thing to do.
You're a bad boy sometimes.
GENEVA CARR: He is bad.
He is bad.
ALAN SEALES: I feel,
Timothy-- Timmy.
Michael, I feel
like you-- sorry.
Timmy, I feel like
you could turn up
the Timmy0 dial
like as you wanted
to you because your character's
all sort of like, what's
up, right?
And I feel like if you turn
that up just a little bit,
it would just go over very
well and making people--
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: Yeah,
there's different frequencies
that I work on, most certainly.
Matinees, they get their own
frequency, Thursday nights.
Saturday nights I fucking
rock out with my cock
out always,
literally-- literally.
Yeah, no, but that's--
LUCAS MCMAHON: Our sales
for Saturday nights
just skyrocketed.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
But, no, that's his play.
I mean, he wrote
this character, man.
There's so much place to play,
man, for all of us really.
ROB ASKINS: Pull your
penis out on stage.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: Rob
wanted dick on stage,
and I was the one that signed
the contract that said, sure.
BOB SAGET: So far,
the sound bites
are rape with a puppet and
rock out with your cock out.
STEVEN BOYER: Rob
wanted dick on stage.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
There is no dick on stage.
You look disappointed.
There's no dick on stage.
I'm sorry.
STEVEN BOYER: I mean,
we're all up there.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: There's
plenty of dicks on stage,
but you just don't see them.
This is a very
serious play, people.
ALAN SEALES: You spend like
10 minutes with your pants
down, at one point.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
Don't say too much, now.
BOB SAGET: That's a
real spoiler alert.
ALAN SEALES: His pants are
down, and I'll leave it at that.
Yeah, Sarah, your character
Jessica is like the only,
I guess-- we'll use air quotes--
"normal: character in the show.
Is that a challenge for you
to just play everything so,
I guess, normal and deadpan?
SARAH STILES: I don't know.
No, I'm going to
name drop right now.
Spielberg came to see
the show, and he said,
Jessica's like the therapist
of the show, which I thought
was so cool.
But, yeah, she's-- I don't know.
I've learned a lot from her.
I have to say, when I get myself
into situations in my own life,
I often wonder, what would
Jessica do right now.
But she's very insightful
and smart and grounded.
Yeah, she's awesome.
ALAN SEALES: So, we've got
another video of Tyrone
that I want to queue up here.
But in the meantime,
if you guys have
any questions for the
cast or Lucas or Rob,
come up to the mics here.
But let's roll that
next video, please
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Yes, I-- I went to Devry.
-Devry acting school?
-That's right.
-I didn't realize they
had an acting school.
ALAN SEALES: They do.
I got a master class from,
um, Freddie Prinze, Jr.
-So at Devry, you met who would
become your best friend, Elmo.
-Whew, OK, (CLEARS
THROAT) yeah, Elmo.
What about him?
-Yeah, they have a
history, and, uh, they
don't get along very well.
-You guys were inseparable.
-Oh, yeah.
-Best friends.
-That's right.
-I know that Tyrone, I think,
was something about "Sesame
Street," and then
Elmo booked it,
and that's definitely--
that definitely has not
been put to bed.
-It was a-- it was
an improv audition.
They said, so we're going to
work with the letter F What
starts with the letter F?
That answer changed
the course of my life.
-Is it true that
Tyrone attacked a man
dressed like Elmo in Times
Square? (WHISPERING) Yeah.
-He lost his mind on this
poor man dressed up like Elmo.
-He was just yelling.
He's like, tickle this.
Tickle this!
-I mean, he took that guy down.
It was frightening.
I didn't know what I was--
people were running in right
and left.
-He went into like
a fugue state.
He doesn't even--
he blacked out.
He doesn't even remember this.
-If Elmo were here right now--
-Is he here?
Is he here?
-He-- he's not here.
-Oh, god, er.
(CLEARS THROAT) I'm sorry.
What's the question?
-If I'm going to
be honest, I think
that he's a little intimidated
by Elmo and his success.
And I think he's
a little jealous.
--[BLEEP] you, you
fuzzy piece of [BLEEP].
My show-- this is
my show, my show.
[END PLAYBACK]
ALAN SEALES: Very cool.
BOB SAGET: They didn't
leave the word "fucking."
You've got to move that.
Slide that over.
ALAN SEALES: Let's get the
lights up on the Q&A over here.
Yeah, we've got a
couple questions
once the lights come up.
Yeah, go ahead.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: Hey,
man, what's going on?
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if you can hear me,
so I will project too.
BOB SAGET: But this is Google.
Shouldn't the audio all be good?
ALAN SEALES: There's
data mining going on
of all of your temperatures.
LUCAS MCMAHON: Actually,
they're all holograms.
That's what is.
STEVEN BOYER: Kanye's going
to ask a question in a second.
AUDIENCE: I was fortunate to
see the plays a few months ago.
I'm from Atlanta,
a visiting Googler.
And so I really was impressed
with the Southern accents
because it's not always the
easiest for non-Southerners
to do our accent.
So in particular, Geneva, I
think yours was really good.
GENEVA CARR: I'm from Atlanta.
I went to Paideia.
AUDIENCE: There you go.
So yours was natural.
For the rest of you,
how do you approach
plain, good old
Southerners from Texas?
SARAH STILES: We
listen to Geneva.
GENEVA CARR: I'm also
the dialect coach.
SARAH STILES: I don't know.
We didn't-- did we have one?
STEVEN BOYER: I mean,
it's in the script.
A lot of it's in the script.
I mean, whenever they say the
word "can't," it's written
"cain't."
I cain't.
I cain't do it.
And we're like, oh, cain't.
Oh, they say
"cain't," all right.
SARAH STILES: How many
syllables does child have?
GENEVA CARR: (SOUTHERN
ACCENT) Child.
STEVEN BOYER: (SOUTHERN
ACCENT) You are a child.
GENEVA CARR: He knows
what I'm talking about.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thanks for coming.
Specifically for the guys
in front, I'm just curious.
The medium of putting this is a
play as opposed to as a musical
or something digital,
prerecorded, movie, TV series,
YouTube vignette--
I'm curious what
was your thought about
putting this specifically
in that medium?
And now that it's
been so successful,
how much you thought
that played into it?
ROB ASKINS: I'm going
to take this one.
LUCAS MCMAHON:
Yeah, you take it.
ROB ASKINS: The thing that
Steve does is miraculous.
What everybody does
onstage is miraculous.
But to watch
somebody in real time
deliver performance
like this is something
the only theater can capture.
Do you know what I mean?
Like on film you could
cut away and go, oh,
that's a special effect,
or they did many takes.
Do you know what I mean?
But to watch it live--
I also think that
there are-- people
don't expect to see
this kind of thing
when they go to the theater.
Do you know what I mean?
There's a lot of blood.
There's a lot of
laughs, and it's
kind of three-chord
punk-rock theater.
ALAN SEALES: There a
lot of blood, actually.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah.
STEVEN BOYER: Blood, sex--
ROB ASKINS: Yeah, and
it's something that--
BOB SAGET: --that
always go together.
ROB ASKINS: If you're
doing it right.
STEVEN BOYER: You've got to
raise your age range, Bob.
BOB SAGET: Please,
let it happen.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah, so
when the audience sees
that, and everybody's
crammed together laughing,
that energy just sort
of multiplies on itself,
and it gets pretty-- it
gets like a rock concert.
LUCAS MCMAHON: And
I will also say
this play is-- we go to the
theater to be surprised.
We go to the theater to
have a live experience
that we feel like we couldn't
see in our everyday life.
As Rob said, a
screen is distancing.
You can do amazing things
on television and movies.
You can do explosions.
You can do car chases.
But to have that
kind of exhilaration,
but all it is these brilliant
actors and a puppet,
that live experience, I
think, is so thrilling.
And I think we as
human beings, we
are hardwired to want to
gather and experience stories.
And I think that what
this man has done,
what these actors do
eight times a week
is they get 800 people
in a room and experience
a full range of emotions.
And they're experiencing
it with people who are
live on stage in front of them.
And I think that's what makes
this show really special.
I think it's what makes the
medium of theatre really
special.
So I think that that is
what these people capture
in their art, and
that's really special
and I think really necessary
to the culture of this world.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, Bob,
you got the benefit
of being able to
come in near the end
here and see a finished,
polished product.
What was your first
impression of the show?
BOB SAGET: Well, I'd seen
the play seven months ago.
Kevin McCollum's
a friend of mine.
I was in "Drowsy Chaperone,"
and I closed that one as well.
So I'm a closer.
But this thing is moving on.
It's going to London with
people that need dental work.
ALAN SEALES: Sound bite.
BOB SAGET: OK, I
shouldn't have said that.
ROB ASKINS: No, that's me.
I need the dental work.
BOB SAGET: Oh, that's
what I was saying, yes.
So I saw the play, and I
was with two of my daughters
and someone else
I can't remember.
I had to put her down.
But I could not believe-- it
is exactly the sensibilities
that I love.
It is exactly
everything that hits
me, which is it's something
very, very serious,
which is people's problems
with their families, to denial,
non-communication,
pain, death, and to be
able to find humor in that.
And there's different places
throughout the play acting
with these people, these
amazing artists, where
as it's been written
by this maestro,
the pressure in the
cooker is building.
And at different
times, it comes out.
And so a lot of times, there
will be very dramatic moment,
and then this humor
comes out, sometimes
out of uncomfortability, because
people have been through this.
People have problems.
People have a child who has a
Tyrone personality, whether it
be-- I mean, I know
people that have
people that go through
similar things,
but not as organic as
a Shari Lewis problem.
Too dated a reference,
sorry Google.
[LAUGHTER]
GENEVA CARR: They can google it.
BOB SAGET: They can google it.
But the play just
touched me deeply,
and I laughed my ass
off, and I thought
it was a miracle when it
was over and one of the best
plays I'd ever seen.
I've seen two other plays.
I saw "Paint Your
Wagon" and [INAUDIBLE].
And one time I got into
Blue Man Group free.
But the thing hit me on
a very, very deep level,
and it is a perfect play.
Every time I'm backstage
thinking about it,
because now I'm past the point
of thinking about myself,
I think about the work.
A great writer, great
writing, answers
the question you have in your
mind the moment you have it.
It takes you to that
moment in the next scene
and in the next
piece of dialogue--
but what happened to?
And they're answering it for
you organically from your gut.
And I also I'm proud
that I'm bringing
my version of Pastor
Greg to the play,
which is a different take.
And I also feel, not unlike
Sarah's character Jessica,
that I have a moral
fulcrum to the play,
that I'm trying to
move things forward.
And as unequipped as I am as a
human being, as Pastor Greg is,
he still loves this
woman, no matter what,
even though his pants are down.
But I never said that.
But it's an amazing work.
And everybody should go
see this play-- everybody.
It closes January 3rd.
You all, everybody in this room,
owe it to yourself to see it,
especially if you have
psychological problems.
And if you work at
Google, odds are--
So we welcome you
and come back stage
and meet Steven and see
the sweat that comes out
of this genius after he's done.
Just smell his sweat, and
you'll become smarter.
ALAN SEALES: Do you enjoy
performing in theater or TV
and film more?
I mean, you've got a little
experience with TV, I guess.
BOB SAGET: I like performing
behind black felt.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah,
totally absolutely.
BOB SAGET: That's right.
STEVEN BOYER:
(WHISPERING) I don't
know what he's talking about.
BOB SAGET: The
first rule of improv
is agree with the psychopath.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah.
BOB SAGET: I love-- I give
1,000% to whatever I'm doing,
so if any women are
interested-- no.
So this play is all I
care about right now.
I love stand up.
I'm going to go on tour in
January and do some stand up.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And I am more Tyrone
than I am anyone else.
But I'm actually
changing and evolving,
and this experience--
every piece of work
you do changes your life.
And these four years these
people have worked on this,
so it'll be a big life
change for everyone.
And so stand up is
something I love.
I actually like
directing the most.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
BOB SAGET: Yeah,
traffic-- I work as a cop.
No, I really do.
I've got a project.
I've directed a bunch of stuff.
ALAN SEALES: I walked
right into that.
BOB SAGET: What?
ALAN SEALES: I walked
right into that.
BOB SAGET: That's what I'm
hoping in traffic you do that.
But I love all the arts.
My favorite is spin
art because you
don't know what you're
going to make when that--
[LAUGHTER]
--goes around.
That was one
question, wasn't it?
40 minutes went by.
ALAN SEALES: It's amazing.
So the--
BOB SAGET: Sorry.
ALAN SEALES: The feedback
from the public, initially
you said it was very good.
Obviously, it's still very good.
Has there been anybody, like
any celebrities, any VIPs who
have come to see
the show who-- like
Mother Teresa showed up and
was like, this is amazing?
Or anybody who has come
that's surprised you?
STEVEN BOYER: Hugh
Jackman saw the show,
and afterwards he seemed
kind of like stunned.
And we're like,
how'd you like it?
And he's like, (AUSTRALIAN
ACCENT) that was bizarre.
We're like, yeah?
And he's just like,
that was bizarre.
ALAN SEALES: The
general feedback
from like critics and
audiences and everything,
has there been anything
that has surprised you
from the audience?
Like do people come
thinking that it's
a legit religious type
of show, or do people
know it's a satire?
GENEVA CARR: Well,
some people have left
because it can be shocking.
But I do not think that
it is offensive to anyone
who is church going.
Like my buddy from Atlanta,
I'm from the deep South,
and my friends have come.
And in their mind, Pastor
Greg does minister us
and does help us, even though I
do some pretty shocking things
with the Bible.
STEVEN BOYER: Very
few have left, though.
Very few, I mean, in the grand
scheme of things have left.
BOB SAGET: I believe if mostly
because of incontinence.
GENEVA CARR: We have had
some people faint through.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
GENEVA CARR: Those are
my favorites, yeah.
SARAH STILES: We
had to stop the show
one because it was a big faint.
STEVEN BOYER: I love that.
BOB SAGET: I wish
I would've done
this thing from the beginning.
ALAN SEALES: Was it
the language that
made them faint, or
like that one scene--
SARAH STILES: The blood.
STEVEN BOYER: There's
a lot of blood.
GENEVA CARR: There's a lot--
there's some scenes that
are pretty gory.
ALAN SEALES: Right,
right, right, yes.
GENEVA CARR: --and
terrifying and unexpected.
And we've had--
STEVEN BOYER: It's got blood.
It's got sex.
It's got puppets.
LUCAS MCMAHON: And you know,
and I think that this is a play
that really aspires
apathy in no one,
which I think is what you aspire
to do when you create theatre.
because there were a couple
like old matinee ladies
who came to the early
one was like, what the?
And just like, they were
horrified, and I loved that.
I think you loved that, too.
BOB SAGET: Oh, yeah.
but they love it though.
LUCAS MCMAHON: Yeah,
and they love it,
and the vast majority
of them, even who
come in expecting something
totally different.
I'll tell you one story that
happened early in previews.
There was another show on
Broadway early this year called
"Act of God" with the
wonderful Jim Parsons.
At our are like third preview,
I was sitting behind a woman
who turned to the man
next to her and went,
(IN NEW YORK ACCENT) is
Jim Parson's in Act Two?
No, he wasn't.
But she left, and she had gotten
there completely by accident.
Thought she was going
to come see Jim Parsons.
He wasn't there.
But she loved the play, so
I think the surprise of this
appealing to people you
wouldn't expected it to appeal
to has been really exciting.
BOB SAGET: I was personally
excited because my television
daughter from a show I once
did, Candace Cameron-Bure came
to the show a couple
weeks ago, and she
is very strong in
her Christian values
and proud of that and a
very dear friend of mine.
And she loved the play.
And we talked
about it at length.
It's not a play
that-- she also loved
that I was a Lutheran minister,
and that I'm getting closer
to what she would like
me to [INAUDIBLE],
and that I find
the Bible sacred.
And then there was quiet.
ALAN SEALES: So the
show, as you said,
it's closing January 3rd
here in New York, but it's--
BOB SAGET: No way.
ALAN SEALES: Moving to London.
So is anything in
the show changing
as it moves across to London?
Is the script
remaining the same?
GENEVA CARR: Aside from the
cast drop, what's changing?
ROB ASKINS: We're going to
see what jokes maintain.
You know what I mean?
Like we're going to see
if there aren't subtle
changes in rhythm
and in content that
maybe help some
of the jokes land,
because jokes are so cultural.
STEVEN BOYER: You're going
to say "brilliant" a lot.
ROB ASKINS: Exactly.
We'll get to use a lot more C
words because they don't have
a problem with that over there.
GENEVA CARR: But it's not an
offensive word over there.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah, exactly.
LUCAS MCMAHON: I
think it's going
to be interesting to
see what audiences
respond to there versus here.
I think a part of
the brilliance of Rob
is that he really
listens to audiences,
and he really listens to
the way actors take a line
and how you can
make it different so
that in their voice it fits in
a way that will make it funnier.
And so I think will be an
interesting experience to see.
Because over there,
they love plays
that are really kind of
like rough and incisive.
But it's a different culture.
It's a different sensibility.
They have a different
sense of humor.
So I think that will
be largely the same,
but it'll be interesting to see.
GENEVA CARR: There have
been so many English people
that have come to see the
show and come up to me.
And I think you're
going You'd be surprised
how much of the
play they're going
to get without assistance.
I think it's universal.
They eat biscuits, you know?
ROB ASKINS: Well, yeah,
and when you have people
even in this country going,
Christian puppetry, really?
You know what I mean.
I feel like there are a lot
of things that will translate.
I feel like isolation and mental
disease are pretty universal.
So is a good sex joke.
ALAN SEALES: So we're
wrapping up time here.
BOB SAGET: This is
really fun though.
Could we keep going?
I mean, it's Google.
Can't you just keep going?
LUCAS MCMAHON: We've got
nowhere to be till 7:00, so.
ALAN SEALES: People have
other meetings to get to.
Yeah, this is a work day.
ROB ASKINS: Yeah, we'll
go to the meetings.
I don't want to promise
anything to these guys.
BOB SAGET: [INAUDIBLE] to go.
I want this to be
like "The Internship"
with Vince Vaughn
and Owen Wilson.
I want to try to come up with
a project, have it spread.
ROB ASKINS: [INAUDIBLE]
buddy comedy
ever-- you and I going to
different meetings at Google.
BOB SAGET: We'll
go to pizza shops.
STEVEN BOYER: I expected
more hover boards today.
Where are the hover boards?
BOB SAGET: What
about the food here?
My god in heaven.
ALAN SEALES: You just want
to talk about just anything
to stay on stage?
BOB SAGET: Now
you understand me.
(SINGING) I had a dream.
ALAN SEALES: All right,
let's see, what could we do?
Steven, if Tyrone used Google,
what would he search for?
STEVEN BOYER: It's a three-way
tie between furry porn, sex
with house plants, and how to
make amphetamines from Imodium
and Vick's VapoRub.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Fair
enough, all right.
BOB SAGET: There is
Google in the play.
I am looking on the computer at
one moment trying to find out
about possession and things.
ALAN SEALES: So you movie type?
BOB SAGET: I'm
actually in my mind
I'm on Google searching-- in
my mind, which is a rough place
to be.
ALAN SEALES: So everyone, if
there's no more live questions,
everyone, remember our
discount go/hadtogod-discount.
Go see the show now
through January 3rd
at the Booth Theater, 222 West
45th Street, @handofgodbroadway
on Twitter and Instagram.
Facebook.com/handofgodbroadway,
handtogodbway.com,
or telecharge for tickets.
Oh, question!
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER: Here we go.
AUDIENCE: We'll do a
live a question, so.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The subtitle
there, "a new American play,"
thank you, for new, and not a
revival of "Paint Your Wagon."
You said American play.
What context?
I mean, it's going to play
well in London you believe.
Is it uniquely American
values or universal or just
you've got to say something?
LUCAS MCMAHON: I can
take that because we're
the ones that put it--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Marketing
people, right?
LUCAS MCMAHON: No, I think that
there's on Broadway right now,
there's-- the season we saw
we were coming into were a lot
of plays that were
imported from London.
And they're all great plays, and
they're all very worthy shows.
But there's something
that's really
special about having
a show that was
created by American audiences.
And there is something uniquely
American about the play.
It doesn't mean that
it's not universal
and it can't play just as well
in London or Paris or South
Africa.
But there is something--
the American spirit
of this play I think is part of
what makes it really special.
So I think that we
were excited when
we went to market the play
about being very open about that
and saying, this was a show
made by American audiences
about the American experience.
And I think that
that's something
that we need more
of on our stages.
And I think that we
thought that that would
get people just excited to--
AUDIENCE: Marketing stake.
LUCAS MCMAHON:
--that sensibility.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BOB SAGET: Originally, it said
a new play from the Philippines,
and nobody was--
LUCAS MCMAHON: It
didn't test well, so.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, one
more question over here.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell us
more about Christian puppetry
because when you
first said that,
I thought you were joking.
But very quickly it became
clear that you weren't joking.
And that was a huge
surprise to me,
so I'd love to hear about it.
ROB ASKINS: This is my
favorite question ever.
This actually really
dovetails very nicely
with the Americaness
of the question.
There's something
really-- there's
a special kind of anxiety
in American Christianity.
And I think the puppet
ministry is very nicely
symbolic of that.
Megachurches are a motherfucker.
And things get weird
in the suburbs.
There's a strange
thing that happens
once you feel like all the
problems have been solved.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, Christ as come,
and everybody's saved,
and why is everybody
still miserable?
I'm going to come back
to puppets, I promise.
I saw your disinterest.
So you're endlessly
purchasing things,
putting a gym in your church
and a Starbucks church,
and a puppets ministry
in your church
hopefully hoping
that you're going
to augment the
religion in some way,
so they finally, the
promised paradise occurs.
It got dark.
Yeah, and so that's
something that my mother did.
My mother was looking for
a place to access a church,
and she liked children, and
puppets seemed innocuous.
And so we bought
a script online.
And you can go on
right now and purchase
everything you need for your
own Christian puppet ministry.
Do you have a more
specific question?
I'm sorry I took that
to a weird place.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it just
seems so bizarre to me.
I was like wondering
like why and how,
and just very basic
newspaper questions.
GENEVA CARR: It's how
you teach children
about Jesus and the Bible,
and you re enact Bible stories
with puppets, and that's
how you get children
involved and indoctrinated.
BOB SAGET: Well, I was raised
Jewish, and I'm Episcopalian,
and I don't understand it.
AUDIENCE: I don't get it.
BOB SAGET: So I
was raised Jewish,
and we would have
holidays, like Purim,
which no one outside of
the faith would know.
And you would dress up.
It was not puppets, but we'd
put on shows as Queen Esther
and Mordecai, which just
sounds like a comedy
team in the Village.
But we would-- but it
was about community,
and it was about
teaching culture.
And it is a way to
segue into getting you
into the religious
beliefs, and it's
true of every-- well,
of a lot of cultures,
but Christianity, for sure.
His experience with
puppet ministry,
you have my empathy forever.
ROB ASKINS: Well,
also, I think, also,
like religion and culture
are stories that we tell
about large groups of people.
And sometimes the rituals
that we create, like Purim,
like even the Seder
dinner, where we act out
parts of the
religious narrative,
like we get to be
the divine, and we
get to be the heroes
in our stories.
BOB SAGET: And talk of things
thousands of years old.
ROB ASKINS: Exactly, so it's
a way to place ourselves
in the tradition.
But, yeah, they're also cute.
GENEVA CARR: It's very Southern.
It's very Southern.
They do it in the South.
This might be why
you don't know it.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, I'm
from North Carolina,
and it didn't seem
out of place to me.
STEVEN BOYER: I'm from Ohio, and
I knew about puppet ministry.
It was something that made
its way to central Ohio.
MICHAEL OBERHOLTZER:
I'm from Indiana.
I'm from the very same
sect of the Lutheran church
as Rob Askins, and
I have never, ever
experienced puppet ministry.
I had no idea what the
fuck this was-- seriously.
So, go figure, right?
ALAN SEALES: All
right, well. we.
BOB SAGET: I was a
virgin until I was 17.
And up to 17, puppets
were all I had.
ROB ASKINS: I love it.
It was good, baby.
BOB SAGET: A little sound bite.
ALAN SEALES: Bob,
you're all done?
You're good?
BOB SAGET: I think so.
You're the first man
that's ever asked me that.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: All right,
handofgodbway.com, give them
another round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
BOB SAGET: Thank you, Google.
LUCAS MCMAHON: Thank
you for having us.
STEVEN BOYER: Thank you so much.